>>> Good morning, ladies and gentlemen, and
welcome. At this time, please take your seats.
We shall begin in two minutes. We shall begin
in two minutes. At this time, as a courtesy
to our presenters, please make sure your cell
phones and any and all mobile devices are
turned off at this time.
Thank you, good morning, and welcome. Please
take your seats.
(Pause).
[ Applause ]
>>> Ladies and gentlemen, please welcome senior
vice president, engineering, Vic Gundotra.
[ Applause ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Well, good morning.
Looks like you're all very excited to be here.
Welcome to Google I/O.
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: You know, this year marks
our fourth year of this conference. And we
thought we'd begin by just reminiscing for
a few moments about how much we have accomplished
together.
You know, you go back to 2008. That was the
first year we held Google I/O. Maybe some
of you were there at our inaugural conference.
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: That year, our opening keynote
focused on client, connectivity, and the cloud.
Why, we recognized that this industry was
going through dramatic change, that mobile
phones, smartphones, and faster Web browsers
were changing the face of clients, and that
connectivity was about to explode, both in
its availability, as well as its bandwidth.
And that would allow us to build cloud-based
services that we could hardly have dreamed
of a few years ago. All that happened.
In 2009, on this stage, we rallied the industry
with the Chrome team to move the Web forward
under the banner of HTML5. And today, modern
browsers are better and faster because of
the work of this group of people.
So thank you.
And then who could forget last year, when
we focused --
[ Laughter ]
>>Vic Gundotra: That was a lot of fun. And
we want to thank all of you for making Android
the global phenomenon that it has become.
Of course, like Android, this conference,
too, has gone truly global. We're very excited
about the 5,000-plus people that are in this
room. But this year, for the first time, we
did something new. We created viewing parties.
We allowed developers to set up their own
viewing parties and stream this event live.
And we have over 110 cities that have these
viewing parties set up.
On the screen behind me at any moment, we
should get a sampling of what's going on around
the world live right now.
We have viewing parties in these 122 cities,
including places like Cairo, where we have
over 1,000 people. It's 2:00 a.m. in the morning
in Cairo.
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: And so to the more than 10,000
people at the viewing parties and the many,
many thousands who are watching, who are watching
on YouTube, welcome to our conference.
We're truly humbled by this worldwide enthusiasm.
We do recognize that you are sharing with
us your most precious resource, your time.
And so we hope the next two days are incredibly
valuable, exciting, and a lot of fun for all
of you.
So let's get this show started. And to do
that, I'd like to introduce Hugo Barra, director
of Android product management, to kick off
the opening keynote.
Hugo.
[ Applause ]
>>Hugo Barra: Well, good morning, everyone,
and welcome to the Android keynote at I/O
2011.
Today, we have three things to talk to you
about: Momentum, mobile, and more.
Let's start with momentum. And I'll ask you
to follow me back in time for just one minute.
Do you guys remember this device?
[ Applause ]
>>Hugo Barra: Of course you do.
Well, this is the T*Mobile G1, the very first
phone we shipped over two and a half years
ago. And it holds a special place in our hearts.
Back then, there were many skeptics. What
did Google know? We had never been in the
mobile space or the operating system business.
Well, from those humble beginnings of one
device and one carrier and one country, how
much progress have we made?
We have so many exciting news to share with
you today. So we made a quick video for you.
Let's have a look.
[ Video. ]
[ Applause ]
>>Hugo Barra: That's right. We're incredibly
thrilled to share with you today that we have
activated over 100 million Android devices
worldwide.
[ Applause ]
>>Hugo Barra: Thank you.
And do you know what the most exciting thing
about this stat is? It's the fact that we
all did it together. 36 OEMs, 215 carriers,
and 450,000 Android developers all over the
world. Thank you!
[ Applause ]
>>Hugo Barra: There are now more than 310
Android devices in 112 countries. Talk about
choice!
And the best way to actually measure this
momentum is velocity. At Google I/O on this
stage last year, Vic shared with you that
we were activating 100,000 Android devices
every day.
By August, that number had doubled to 200,000.
Then 300,000 in December. And today, we are
activating over 400,000 Android devices every
single day.
[ Applause ]
>>Hugo Barra: Now, there's a reason why you're
all here today. It's because you write software.
And most of you write Android apps.
Well, thanks to your extremely hard work,
I'm excited to announce today that we've exceeded
the mark of 200,000 applications available
in Android Market.
[ Applause ]
>>Hugo Barra: And of course what really matters
is that the quality of these applications
is phenomenal.
CNN, Flixter, Fruit Ninja, Tap Tap Revenge,
Major League Baseball, Gun Brothers, Pulse,
and so many more. The world's most engaging,
useful, and entertaining mobile applications
are running on Android.
And the most important thing for you, Android
developer, is the tremendous growth in application
downloads. Here's some data: It took the Android
ecosystem almost two years to see the first
billion application installs.
It then took just five months to get to the
second billion.
Well, today, we're seeing one billion downloads
in less than 60 days, and a total of over
four and a half billion application installs
from Android Market up until today, four and
a half billion application installs.
Android Market is seeing stronger, faster
growth than ever.
And that reminds me to pause and once again
thank you, Android developer, for your amazing
support and hard work over the last two and
a half years. You have been truly phenomenal,
and the entire ecosystem is now being rewarded.
So thank you, and thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>>Hugo Barra: So this wraps up the section
about momentum of this keynote.
And now there are two other parts: Mobile
and more.
In mobile, we're going to cover the Android
platform and talk about some of the features
on our road map.
We're also going to show you two exciting
new services that we're announcing today.
And then we'll talk about more and give you
a preview of the future, where Android is
headed as an open platform and an open ecosystem,
going, let's say, well beyond the mobile phone.
I'd like to welcome two people on stage, Anand
Agarwala, from the Android product team, will
drive our demos today. And to talk about Android
platform, please welcome Mike Cleron, from
the Android engineering team.
[ Applause ]
>>Mike Cleron: Thanks, Hugo.
Well, we've been busy. Over the last two and
a half years, the Android team has already
shipped eight releases of the Android platform.
Today, I'm going to tell you what's coming
next.
First, we're announcing an upgrade to Honeycomb,
Android 3.1. We're rolling it out today, starting
with Verizon XOOM 3G customers. It's not been
very long since we first launched Honeycomb,
but we've managed to get a lot of nice user
enhancements into the 3.1 upgrade. Let me
show you a couple of them. First, people really
like the new task switcher we introduced in
Honeycomb. You can see it here.
We figured if switching between a few tasks
was good, then switching between more will
be even better. We made it so you can scroll
through to see all of your most recent tasks.
Remember that Android has true multitasking.
So some of these apps may really be running
and some may not. But the user doesn't need
to care.
This is possible only on Android, because
we're using some unique technology that automatically
shuts down and restores applications transparently.
The system manages resources for you so you'll
never run out of memory and you'll never be
asked to quit in order to launch something
else.
Next, remember the improved widgets we introduced
in Honeycomb? Let's look at the scrolling
GMail widget.
That's pretty nice. But what if you get a
lot of mail?
Well, for that, we're taking widgets to the
next level.
[ Applause ]
>>Mike Cleron: So as you can see, you can
now stretch widgets horizontally or vertically.
And if you're a developer and you've already
created a scrolling widget for Honeycomb,
you can upgrade it to be resizable with just
a few lines of XML.
In 3.1, we also put a lot of effort into upgrading
Droid's USB support. Android devices can now
act as USB hosts, which means you can now
do things like --
[ Applause ]
>>Mike Cleron: Yeah.
So that means you can now do things like importing
photos directly from your digital camera to
your tablet.
[ Applause ]
>>Mike Cleron: And because Android is now
a USB host, the OS also supports a ridiculous
number of USB input devices as well, keyboards,
mice, trackpads, joysticks, game controllers,
and more.
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Mike Cleron: So here you're about to see
Anand play, or, rather, attempt to play, Cordy
using a game controller.
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
>>Mike Cleron: Okay, well, that was a brave
attempt.
There's a lot more in 3.1. But let me move
on to some other platform news.
It turns out that Android 3.1 is not just
for tablets. It's also coming to Google TV
this summer. This is great news for Google
TV users.
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Mike Cleron: It's great news for Google
TV users. And it gets better. Google TV will
also be getting the Android Market. So all
of you developers --
[ Applause ]
>>Mike Cleron: So all of you developers will
now be able to create apps for Google TV using
exactly the same SDK that you're using for
Honeycomb. Consumers who already have a Google
TV device will automatically get the upgrade
over the air. And there are new Google TV
products based on 3.1 coming from Sony, Vizio,
Samsung, and Logitech.
If you want to hear more about bringing your
apps to Google TV, please check out the Google
TV session tomorrow here at I/O.
Let's look a little farther down the road.
I'm also happy to announce the next major
Android release, Ice Cream Sandwich. And,
of course, to also debut the most important
part of any release, the new logo.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
>>Mike Cleron: All right. We're targeting
a Q4 launch for Ice Cream Sandwich. And in
many ways, this will be our most ambitious
release to date.
Let me tell you about some of the themes behind
this release.
First, choice. If I had to pick one word to
explain Android's phenomenal growth over the
past year, that word would be "choice."
Consumers really like choices. And with Ice
Cream Sandwich, we're going to make them really,
really happy.
Here's just a small sample of the range of
devices that we've powered by Android.
So we have phones in every size and shape;
phones with keyboards that slide; phones with
keyboards that flip; phones with built-in
game controllers; tablets in every size from
seven inches to ten inches; even tablets that
transform into laptops. And who knows what
else is coming.
But in the end, we know that high-quality
apps are the lifeblood of Android. So our
top priority for Ice Cream Sandwich will be
to give app developers the tools they need
to deliver great experiences on all of these
devices. We want one OS that runs everywhere.
Let me tell you how we're going to make that
happen.
To start, we're taking all of the good stuff
that we added to Honeycomb for tablets and
we'll make it available everywhere, on phones,
on tablets, on everything in between.
This includes the new holographic UI, the
new launcher, the new multitasking UI, richer
widgets, advanced applications, everything.
Next, we're investing heavily in the application
framework. We want to insulate developers
from the differences between all of those
devices as much as possible.
So we're adding new APIs to the framework
to help scale your UI across all these different
form factors. And we're adding intelligence
to components like the action bar. They'll
be able to reconfigure themselves to optimize
for the available space.
We're also putting a lot of energy into our
development tools.
Be sure to check out the Android tools talk
tomorrow at 3:00 for some exciting developments
there.
And last, but certainly not least, it will
all be open source.
[ Applause ]
>>Mike Cleron: Now, Ice Cream Sandwich is
not just about breadth. It's about depth,
too.
On Android, we're always looking to bring
the latest technology to mobile devices. And
we've got some really cutting-edge stuff in
the works.
Anand is going to help me demo some of the
latest developments from Google's Technology
Extraction Team based in Roswell, New Mexico.
[ Laughter. ]
>>Mike Cleron: For real.
Basically, this technology can look at the
input from the camera and figure out where
your head is and even where you're looking.
It runs on the GPU, so it can do all that
insanely fast. It can process 500 frames a
second.
So let's have some fun with that.
First, watch what happens as Anand moves his
head from side to side.
Because the software knows where he's looking,
it can update the 3D scene in real time to
match his perspective.
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Mike Cleron: Okay.
How about this? We cannot only detect where
Anand's head is but we also know where his
eyes, nose, and mouth are.
Now, Anand is a handsome guy, but there's
always room for a little improvement. So let's
fix him up.
Okay. That's not really a good look. Maybe
something in the nose area.
Okay. That's pretty unfortunate.
Maybe eyes a little smaller?
Wow. Okay.
[ Laughter ]
>>Mike Cleron: I think the lesson here is
not to attempt to improve on nature.
Let's move on to something more practical.
We call it virtual camera operator.
Let's say Anand and Hugo are together on a
video chat. The software can actually figure
out by itself who is speaking and will automatically
focus on the right person.
Let's give that a try.
>>Anand Agarwala: Anand Agarwala So you can
see here as I start talking, it zooms in smoothly
to my face.
>>Hugo Barra: Then when I start talking after
a few seconds, the camera realizes that I'm
here and it's going to zoom in on my face
automatically.
[ Applause ]
>>Anand Agarwala: When I start talking again,
it zooms fluidly back to me with a smooth,
fluid back and forth transition.
[ Applause ]
>>Mike Cleron: That's pretty amazing.
And note that this is not just for fun. All
of this and more will be available as developer
APIs in Ice Cream Sandwich so all of you can
create great new experiences.
That's just a quick peak at what's coming
in 2011 for the Android platform. We're really
excited about moving Android forward and can't
wait to see what all of you will build with
it.
Thanks very much.
[ Applause ]
>>Mike Cleron: Hugo, back to you.
>>Hugo Barra: Thank you, Mike. Thank you,
that was great.
So we had a little bit of fun with Anand.
We showed you a new dessert. And we talked
about the importance of one Android OS everywhere.
We're now going to shift topics and talk about
media.
Today, we're announcing a couple of new services
that we think you'll really enjoy. And to
talk about the first one, here is Chris Yerga
from the Android cloud services team.
>>Chris Yerga: Thank you, Hugo. Today users
can go to Android Market to get applications
as well as books.
We added the books tab to Android Market back
in February of this year, and the way it works
with books on Android Market, whether it's
from the Android Market Web site or from your
Android device, that book is instantly available
to read across all your devices.
Now, we're able to do this because your book
purchase is tied to your Google account, not
to any specific device.
I'm happy to announce that we are bringing
this same experience to Android Market for
movies as well.
[ Applause ]
>>Chris Yerga: Starting today, users can rent
movies from Android Market and instantly stream
them via the cloud to their computers or to
their Android devices.
We have a selection of thousands of titles
available to rent, competitively priced starting
at $1.99. It's seamless and I am going to
walk you through it right now.
We are going to start off with Android Market
on the Web.
So here you see the Android Market Web site,
and you will notice that the home page of
Android Market now shows featured content
from applications, books, and movies.
If we click into the movies section we will
be taken to the movies home page on Android
Market. And the movies home page shows featured
content, new releases, there's categories
to browse and of course search, and here at
the top left we have a section of top rentals
that shows the most popular rentals. So why
don't we pick one of those, The King's Speech.
Good choice. Something highbrow for this time
of day.
And the rental process is very easy. Simple
click on the "rent" button, confirmation dialogue
to complete your rental.
Now, the way this works is that movies on
Android Market have a 30-day rental period
during which you can begin watching your movie,
and then once you have started watching, you
have 24 hours to complete viewing of your
movie.
Now, I could view the movie right here on
the Android Market Web site, streamed from
the cloud, but the movies look terrific on
the tablet. So I would like to switch over
to the Xoom right now. And on the Xoom tablet,
we have a new movies application. And so you
see it there on the home page, when we tap
on the videos app, we're going to go in here,
and you will notice that the movie that I
just rented from the Web is now showing up
here in the movies application, ready to stream
in high definition to my tablet from the cloud.
Now, I can't always stream videos live from
the cloud. The cloud feature is terrific,
but if I'm on an airplane and I don't have
data connectivity, I still want to be able
to watch the movie I rented. We are able to
do this with a feature we call pinning.
So we go in here and select a couple of these
movies and pin them to the device.
What pinning means is that these movies will
then be automatically in the background, downloaded
to the device, so that when I do get on the
airplane, I will have my movie available and
ready.
But while those are downloading, why don't
we back out and show what playback looks like
on the tablet.
Pick a movie. Despicable Me. Good choice.
And so playback is terrific. This is a high
def experience. We can play and pause, jump
around to more interesting bits of the movie,
and all of these movies are available to play
both here on your tablet as well as on the
Web site. But we don't want phones to be left
out of the mix, either. So we're going to
show you phones in a second as well. But before
we do, I want to show you that in addition
to playing back movies, we can also rent the
movies directly here from the tablet.
So the shop link at the top takes you directly
to Android Market. Android Market, you will
notice, has a new movies tab, very similar
to the apps in books tabs with featured content,
best sellers, category browsing, et cetera.
Why don't we go ahead and look at something
from the featured carousel and pick something
to rent.
And the rental experience on the tablet is
very similar to the one that you saw on the
Web. A quick tap on the rent button, confirmation
dialogue. And then once the rental is complete,
you will be able to watch your movie here
on the tablet or on the Web or on the phone.
And so now I would like to switch over to
the phone, and show you the new movies application
there.
And so the movies application on the phone
will show the exact same movies that we have
just rented, both from the Web and from the
tablet, ready once again to stream live from
the cloud to my device.
So that is movies on Android Market. We made
it really easy for you to rent anywhere and
watch anywhere.
We have a selection of thousands of movies
available. And so I'd like to invite everyone
to go to market.android.com and try out our
new movies rental experience.
The tablet application that we showed you
is rolling out as part of our Honeycomb 3.1
update, that Mike mentioned earlier. That
is going out to Verizon Xoom 3G users starting
today. And the movies application on the phone
is going to be available to Android 2.2 devices
starting in a couple of weeks.
Thank you very much.
>>Hugo Barra: Thank you, Chris.
[ Applause ]
>>Hugo Barra: Chris just showed you how seamless
it is to rent a movie and then play it on
the Web, on your phone or on your tablet,
seamlessly.
We want it make it just as easy for you to
enjoy the content that you already own, from
any device, seamlessly.
We just talked about movies. What's the other
type of content that we all really enjoy?
Of course you know the answer. To talk to
us about a new service from Google, here is
Paul Joyce.
[ Applause ]
>>Paul Joyce: Thank you, Hugo.
Today we're introducing music beta by Google.
[ Applause ]
>>Paul Joyce: When you add your music to the
new service, you can listen on the Web, or
any compatible device. No wires, no painful
syncing.
Your music collection is stored in the cloud,
so you can stop worrying about where your
songs are and start enjoying your music.
[ Applause ]
>>Paul Joyce: Perhaps you heard a rumor or
two so let me show you how it works.
This is music manager, a program for Windows
and Mac that helps you add your songs to the
new music service. You can select specific
folders, but if you pick your iTunes or Windows
Media Player library, all of your play lists,
play counts, and ratings are added along with
your songs.
So let's jump to the browser. In a second
you will see the album view of my music library,
but I can browse by songs, artists, and genres.
Music on the Web is a full featured music
manager with everything you would expect:
Search, info editing, ratings, and play counts.
Let's go to the home view. It displays recently
played and recently added music.
Now let's drill into the album detail view.
Love that transition. Just double-click on
a song and it plays right away.
All of my existing play lists are there on
the left and I quickly create new ones. Select
a couple songs, drag them over, and name the
play list.
When I create the IO Jams play list, it's
available right away on all my devices, my
tablet, my phone, or any other computer.
But to make creating play lists even easier,
we have a new feature. We can build a play
list automatically for you based on any song
you like. We call this instant mix.
Let's say I am in the mood for some Earth,
Wind and Fire. Notice the search suggestions
that appear right away as you type.
Select a song, and instant mix selects 25
tracks from your library that go great together.
To do this, we look at artist similarity,
and unlike some other smart play list creation
tools, our model literally listens to your
music. With machine learning, we find similar
tracks based on how they sound to build a
truly ingenious mix.
[ Applause ]
>>Paul Joyce: So that's music beta on the
Web. Let's shift over to my mobile devices.
So here is the latest version of Android music
app running on my tablet. This is the same
UI we shipped with the first Honeycomb release
and it looks really sharp.
This is the 3D carousel, and we can switch
over to the artist's wall to highlight a few
other effects.
It's so cool when he does that.
And of course it will show all my local music.
But there's one very awesome difference. This
app connects to the music service to access
all of my music in the cloud. And that means
I'll never have to use a cable to add music
again.
[ Applause ]
>>Paul Joyce: So let's switch over to the
play list view. Here are all my play lists,
including -- there they are -- the IO Jams
play list and the instant mix we just created
on the Web. No wires, no painful syncing.
It's all just available instantly.
Let's switch over to the album view. Having
all of my music available to me wherever,
whenever is extremely powerful. But for times
when I don't have a data connection on my
tablet or phone, we wanted to create an easy
way to enjoy your music off-line, too. And
we came up with two things.
First, we cache music I have recently played.
So without doing anything, I have access to
a selection of songs when I am off line.
And second, I can select albums, play lists
and artists using the same make available
off-line feature that Chris showed you for
movies.
So let's switch over to the phone.
The phone has the same capabilities we just
demonstrated. Cloud music access, off-line
caching. There's the 3D UI. Because it's exactly
the same application download.
But when it's running on Froyo or Gingerbread
instead of Honeycomb, the UI is optimized
for the smaller screen. For example, in portrait
mode, navigation is more list driven and you
can swipe to change views.
Like on the Web and tablet, I can create and
edit play lists or make an instant mix, and
they become instantly available everywhere.
The best part, if I get a brand-new phone,
all I have to do is sign in, and my music
is right there right away.
[ Applause ]
[ Music ]
>>Paul Joyce: Didn't we play Shining Star
last year?
I guess that's my reminder to talk about availability.
So we're really excited about this service.
It's launching in beta today, and we're going
to roll it out in stages. Initially by invitation
only to U.S. users.
You can add up to 20,000 songs to your library.
And at least while it's in beta, the service
is free.
[ Applause ]
>>Paul Joyce: So all of you attending Google
I/O who are based in the United States will
get an invitation.
[ Applause ]
>>Paul Joyce: We thought you'd like that part.
You will receive an e-mail today with instructions
to get started. And if you are on the Webcast,
we invite you to visit music.google.com to
learn more details and request your invitation.
Finally, we're releasing the updated music
app on Android Market today. Any Android 2.2
or higher device, download the new app and
it will work with music stored in your phone
even while you are waiting for an invitation.
So thank you. Back to you, Hugo.
[ Cheers and Applause ]
>>Hugo Barra: Thank you, Paul.
Thank you. That was awesome!
So Honeycomb 3.1, Ice Cream Sandwich, movie
rentals, and movies. How do you guys think
we are doing so far?
The kind of innovation that you saw here today
has been the driving force behind Android's
success.
But of course that innovation only matters
if it can actually reach consumers.
So today, we're announcing a founding team
of industry leaders, including many partners
from the open handset alliance that Google
is going to work with on this.
Together we'll create new guidelines for how
quickly devices will get updated after new
Android platform releases.
[ Cheers and Applause ]
>>Hugo Barra: Thank you.
And for how long they will continue to get
updated after that.
[ Applause ]
>>Hugo Barra: The founding partners are: Verizon,
HTC, Samsung, Sprint, Sony Ericsson, LG, T*Mobile,
Vodafone, Motorola, and AT&T.
[ Applause ]
>>Hugo Barra: And we're welcoming others to
join us, of course.
To start, we're jointly announcing today that
new devices from these partners will receive
the latest Android platform updates for 18
months after their first launch if the hardware
allows. And that's just the beginning. Stay
tuned in for more on this soon.
[ Applause ]
>>Hugo Barra: We think -- Thank you.
We think this is really great news for users.
It's excellent for developers, and it's really
great for the entire industry.
So let's move on.
Let's transition now to the section about
more.
Today we'd like to unveil some of the Android
team's vision for the future of computing
and applications. Think of it as a beginning
of the next Wave of Android.
As an open platform, Android was always meant
to go well beyond the mobile phone, and today
we wanted to give you a little taste of that.
We want to enable developers to do a lot more
with Android, to write apps for new classes
of hardware, and why not? Even create their
own hardware.
And we want to do that in a way that takes
the concept of openness to a new level.
I'd like to you meet Matt Hershenson and Joe
Britt from the Android hardware engineering
team. They have been working on a few exciting,
really cool projects that they want to talk
to you about.
So Matt is going to get started, and Joe will
come after.
[ Applause ]
>>Matt Hershenson: Thanks, Hugo.
As you heard earlier, there are over 300 Android
devices in the market. We know hardware developers
would love to have a way to build accessories
that can work with any device from any manufacturer.
Until now, that's been hard, but that's about
to change.
Today, we're announcing Android open accessory.
We are adding platform support for hardware
accessories and a new API to talk to them.
Using these, you can build a wide range of
accessories and they will work with any Android
device going forward.
Let me show you a demo.
Everyone uses their phone for music at the
gym but what if your Android device could
integrate more fully with your workout.
This is an exercise bike made with Life Fitness
and it's compatible with open accessory. Anand
is going to get ready for a workout on it.
First, put on his head band. Most importantly,
he has his Android phone. Now he is going
to dress for his workout.
[ Cheers ]
>>Matt Hershenson: People go crazy for his
legs.
Now, watch what happens when he plugs the
phone into the bike.
It recognizes the accessory, and it shows
an application that knows how to talk to it.
If the phone didn't already have a compatible
app, the bike would just send the user to
the app in Android Market to download it.
This is really cool! If a user buys an accessory
that needs an app, when they connect the phone
to the accessory, it just takes them where
they need to go to get that app.
Okay. So Anand is now going to launch CardioQuest,
and then the exercise bike actually recognizes
that it's been connected to the Android phone.
He is going to select an easy workout, and
then the API is actually going to have the
bike control the game that he is going to
play.
Now, see, as he pedals faster, he moves the
Android guy up. He pedals slower, he moves
the Android guy down.
Ohhhh. Whoa! One calorie, one calorie.
You do that a thousand more times, and you
can have one of those ice cream sandwiches
at the after party.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
>>Matt Hershenson: How do you think he got
those legs?
So you can check out the exercise bike and
actually play the game later on in the interactive
zone.
Today we're making the Android open accessory
API available for Honeycomb and Gingerbread.
It supports USB now and Bluetooth support
will come in the future.
[ Applause ]
>>Matt Hershenson: So it's not just about
software. It's about hardware, too.
And we want to provide a complete solution.
So today, we're releasing the hardware and
software for an Android open accessory reference
design. We're calling it the ADK, for Android
Accessory Development Kit. Here it is.
The ADK is based on Arduino, and a USB host
--
[ Applause ]
>>Matt Hershenson: It also incorporates circuitry
from a USB host from Circuits@Home, and I
think by the applause, people already know
Arduino is an open platform with tons of third-party
hardware and software add-ons that developers
can use to develop Android accessories.
The ADK isn't the only way. Microchip and
RT Corporation are each launching their own
open accessory compatible development boards
today.
Let's take a look at one of these ADK boards
in action.
Here we have a labyrinth game and we have
added two off-the-shelf servo motors to it,
and those are hooked up to this ADK board.
The ADK board then is communicating to the
tablet.
The tablet is running a simple app which sends
the accelerometer data over USB to the ADK
which is then controlling the tilt of the
labyrinth to match the tablet. All I need
to do, I tilt it to get the ball out; okay?
So the object of the game is to tilt the platform
to make the ball follow the line and go all
the way to the end without falling into any
of the -- oh -- holes. You got to three. A
little better than the calorie count but it's
clear you need practice at both.
[ Laughter ]
>>Matt Hershenson: So we thought this little
labyrinth game was cool, was cute, like the
legs.
[ Laughter ]
>>Matt Hershenson: But we wanted something
a little bigger to match the success of Android.
We couldn't even fit it on the stage, but
we have a video.
Let's roll the video.
Android's been a huge success and we think
the ADK and Android open accessory will be,
too.
This labyrinth was inspired by that. It weighs
about 5,000 pounds and is powered by a pair
of 200 volt 50-amp motors.
It's all controlled by the Android tablet
hooked up through an ADK, much like the one
on stage.
If you want to learn more about Android open
accessory and the ADK and to learn how to
get started working on your own accessories,
please visit the session this afternoon at
1:15 or visit accessories.Android.com.
[ Applause ]
>>Hugo Barra: So now you know what that giant
covered object in the glass fenced area by
the escalator is. That's the super labyrinth.
The demo will be available for to you play
with. It's a ton of fun, after the keynote
and for the next two days. Definitely check
it out. I predict there will be a big line.
With the ADK, we are welcoming hardware developers
into the Android community, and giving them
a path to building great Android accessories
quickly and easily.
One important note. This program is completely
open. There are no NDAs, there are no fees,
there is no approval process to build a hardware
accessory or write the software that goes
with it. So get started.
[ Applause ]
>>Hugo Barra: Step one is go to the interactive
zone where you will see a bunch of open accessory
powered accessories from our partners and
there's some great stuff there so check it
out.
Now, Joe Britt is here, I believe, to talk
to you about an even larger type of accessory.
Joe.
>>Joe Britt: We want to go one step further.
What exactly is an Android accessory?
We'd like to think of your entire home as
an accessory, or better yet, as a network
of accessories, and think of Android as the
operating system for your home.
We call this vision Android@Home.
At the center of the Android@Home architecture
is your Android device. We're extending the
Android OS to include new services that allow
Android apps to discover, connect, and communicate
with appliances and devices in the home. We
call this the Android@Home Framework.
For appliances that cannot connect to Wi-Fi,
we've designed an open, wireless protocol
that allows Android devices to talk to them.
This new protocol enables very low-cost connectivity
with anything that's electrical in your home,
such as lights, alarm clocks, thermostats,
dishwashers, et cetera.
We want to think of every appliance in your
home as a potential I/O device for Android
apps.
So let's take a look at a couple of demos
of this stuff. Let's bring the stage lights
down just a little.
And now, Anand, would you like to show the
audience the trick you just learned?
>>Anand Agarwala: Yes, I would.
MMMMM, MMMMM, (Making noises).
[ Laughter ]
>>Joe Britt: Okay, okay. Anand is taking a
little theatrical license. What we just demonstrated
was a simple hello world type app on his tablet
that displays a series of digital light switches.
Using the Android@Home framework, this tablet
can talk wirelessly to these two floor lamps
so Anand can turn them on and off. The other
two switches are linked to these super-bright
audience lights left and right. And Anand
can also control them wirelessly.
Okay. Now that you know how to control the
lights, you can let your imagination as a
developer completely take over.
Imagine the new ways you'll be able to deliver
notifications. You can build an alarm clock
app that slowly ramps up the lights in the
room and starts playing your favorite music
through the stereo as the alarm time approaches.
Or imagine how your applications could tie
in the calendar to automatically control home
devices.
If you're a game developer, think about how
this functionality could make game play more
immersive. Imagine using the Android@Home
framework to control an irrigation system
and enable a real-world Farmville app.
[ Laughter ]
>>Joe Britt: If you don't win the game, if
you don't win the game, then your garden dies,
right? So there's significant incentive to
do a good job.
As a quick example of this idea, we hooked
the stage lights up to Quake. And so as Anand
plays the game -- we'll see it up here on
the screen -- and fires shots, you'll see
these lights Flash. These are actually connected
to the game. It's communicated through Android@Home
and controlling these lights.
Okay, okay, you get the idea with that.
So to bring this vision to reality, we're
partnering with several industry players.
One I'd really like to mention is Lighting
Science, one of the world's leading LED lighting
technology manufacturers.
They'll start selling the first LED lightbulbs
and switches for the Android@Home environment
for the end of this year. Prototypes of their
Android@Home-compatible bulbs are being used
here in these on-stage lamps.
We also have a number of Android@Home-enabled
devices available for you to play with in
the interactive zone. So please stop by and
check them out.
All right. I'm going to walk over to the other
side of the stage. The next thing I'd like
to show you is a totally new kind of Android
device. It's an Android@Home hub. It's both
a stand-alone music beta end point and a bring
to the Android@Home network. We call it Project
Tungsten. Let's take a look at a couple of
actual devices. These are our reference designs.
All right. What we have here are two tungsten
devices. A tungsten device runs the Android
OS and the Android@Home Framework. It's always
powered on and always connected to the cloud.
It has audio out. And these examples can connect
to either speakers or my home stereo system.
So let's bring the stage lights down again
just so I can show you something else cool.
If you hadn't noticed, they have these crazy
lights on them. And look at the shape of this
thing. I know that Mike Cleron earlier mentioned
our Roswell extraction team. Well, I mean,
how could this be anything but alien technology?
All right.
So we can bring the lights up a little bit
now.
So what exactly do these do?
Earlier today, Paul showed you our music beta
service on a phone and on a tablet.
Here, we have the same music service, but
working with these new devices. So Anand,
let's turn up the volume on one of them.
[ Music ]
>>Joe Britt: You can imagine that this device
is playing music in, say, your living room.
If we take a look at the tablet Anand is using,
we can see he's in the music app. But there's
a new feature to select an output device.
The tablet can direct music to one or more
Tungsten boxes like the one we have here.
Anand, why don't you start music on both of
them.
You can enjoy your music synchronized throughout
your house, all streaming through Music Beta.
When Anand tapped on those buttons, the music
stream was sent transparently from one box
to another. Since the boxes are running Android,
they just pull the music directly from the
music library in the cloud.
All right. All this functionality that you've
seen here is part of the Android@Home Framework.
And it will be completely open for developers
to explore and write their own applications.
To give you an example of the kinds of applications
we have in mind, we've put together a very
simple demo. This is actually another Tungsten.
It looks very different from those, but it's
another example of the device.
So when we show you this example, I want you
to keep in mind this is just a conceptual
example. It's not an actual product.
Imagine these CDs shipped with a Near Field
Communications inside the jewel case which
activates when you take off the packaging.
He is going to take one of the CDs, run DMC
and touch it to this device.
(chime)
>>Joe Britt: That chime means it's been added
to my library, the entire CD.
[ Applause ]
>>Joe Britt: Thank you. If he touches it again,
it starts playing.
So that's pretty cool; right?
We could add another CD, like Santana, and
start playing it.
[ Music ]
>>Joe Britt: Okay. Well, that's it for this
Android@Home preview.
We hope that you can see how this combination
of new cloud services, software, and devices
enables a whole new universe of applications.
You will hear a lot more about Android@Home
over the next few months.
Thank you, guys.
[ Applause ]
>>Hugo Barra: Thanks, Joe. That was really
fun.
I'll remind you that there's a lot of applications
today doing crazy things, using location,
gyroscope, insane GPU graphics that most of
us wouldn't have thought possible, even two
years ago. So what we're doing here is creating
new possibilities with open accessory and
Android@Home with the expectation that your
imagination as a developer is really going
to make it flourish. There's going to be a
lot more details coming on these shortly.
But we wanted to show you a quick preview,
just a little taste for where the Android
team is going.
Let's do a quick recap.
We covered quite a lot today.
In momentum, we talked about 100 million devices
and four and a half billion application installs.
Then in mobile, we covered Honeycomb 3.1 for
tablets and also Google TV. We talked about
Ice Cream Sandwich, the new Android platform
release, one Android OS everywhere. We talked
about media in the cloud with movie rentals
and music both launching today.
We also talked about a new industry partnership
to bring the latest Android innovation to
users faster.
And then we talked about more. We talked about
Android Open Accessory, which you just saw,
and our vision for Android@Home devices and
applications.
Was that almost too much for 51 minutes?
[ Applause ]
>>Hugo Barra: Now, there are some unbelievably
cool Android devices coming out now and over
the next few weeks and months, with really
interesting new form factors and awesome new
features. In fact, an example is this device
right here. This is the new Samsung 10.1 tab.
It's a great new device with a dual-core processor.
It's got a super-sharp screen that's 720p
video capable. It's got dual-band Wi-Fi support.
It's really slick. It's thinner and lighter
than you'd ever imagine.
This device is going to launch in about a
month or so. So it's not available to anyone
yet, with one exception.
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Hugo Barra: Thanks -- thank you -- thanks
to Samsung, all 5,000 of you are getting one
today.
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Hugo Barra: So you'll be able to get your
device over the next couple of days. There's
no need to rush, including at the party tonight.
[ Laughter ]
>>Hugo Barra: This device comes with Honeycomb
3.0. And it will get Honeycomb 3.1, which
is rolling out today, over the next couple
of weeks.
We hope you enjoy this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Hugo Barra: Now, just a couple of quick
announcements.
We've designed 22 sessions at Google I/O this
year specifically focused on Android development
topics with in-depth content prepared and
delivered by Android engineers. So check those
out.
And to see what the latest schedule is -- there
have been a few minor changes -- download
the Google I/O app if you haven't already
for your tablet or phone.
I should also tell you tomorrow at 10:45,
we're going to be making some Android Market
announcements of some user and developer features
which I think you'll enjoy. So check that
out as well. It will also be on livecast.
And lastly, let me just once again thank you,
Android developers, for your phenomenal support.
I look forward to talking to you, most of
you or many of you, at the conference today
and of course at the party tonight.
So thank you, and have a great Google I/O.
[ Applause ]